e siccome ragazzi io ci tengo a
mantenere le promesse siamo tornati su
scrive l'ansa limited signori miei
abbiamo esattamente 60 st wright quindi
posso fare questa parte completamente
nuova che non avevo fatto l'altra volta
cioè perché dice che devo arrivare a 60
per sbloccarmi la ma in realtà era la
parte iniziale questa cosa succede se
arrivo lì a 60 quello fatto sia volta
nella 60 giusto non ne ho 58 ma qui già
la cagata iniziale l'ho detta fantastico
galleria della pirgo ap c'è un sacco di
posti scuola calamaio dove non ho preso
la mia st wright quindi andiamo a
prenderne due vediamo cosa succeda
quella roba lì pensavo di avaria 60
scusate giorno la madonna cos'è perbacco
sta cominciando a crescere poi dovrai
darle ciò di cui corpo di una creatura
ha bisogno
la quarta stagione della casa dovrei
darle un nome
metti le lettere sulla tela e premi
l'interruttore con l'inter tutto questo
ecco qua era molto più semplice del
previsto
[Risate]
bellissimo e la mia più bella stella di
scriverlo sono e grecia o giampiero
esperimento scientifico folle completato
ma altro che kartoffeln ho fatto tutte
le micro missioni quindi dovrebbe finita
non veniva anche ancora una maledizione
voglio incontrare qualcuno che stia
facendo che sta facendo carriera eccomi
attore intrattenimento eccolo sono
ovviamente meno interessante di un
attore teste di ca corà manca una micro
missione voglio far ridere divertente
adesso sì eccolo a tappa 60 st wright
ragazzi fai la fattoria di lì per
sbloccare di lui livelli ma ancora dopo
il 60 la donna dopo 60 star ai temi
sblocca al con la roba quanto è lungo
soggiorno cielo gioco dal 2013 sono
passati sette anni basta il perdurare
sono queste ai 7 anni ancora sta
succedendo la sorella la tua prigionia è
durata sette fottutissimi anni non so se
hai capito
7 a posto e lo salva
e non devo e allo star write materazzi a
tutto ciò che max l'aveva fatto per
cercare di salvarmi prego ho finito
scrivere ho finito scriverlo dopo sette
anni mica gameplay più lungo della
storia
ho finito ragazzi io ho giocato a
scriverla per sette anni e ho finito
adesso il mio più lungo gameplay vai ci
ho messo così tanto a finire un gioco ma
perché io allora in realtà ma perché in
realtà il gioco era già finito a vi
spiego io poi lavoro finito dopo una
novizia ci ho messo anche c'è un sacco
di tempo ai tempi definirlo tipo un
annetto tutto perché volevo abbandonato
velo ripreso poi abbandonato per i preso
un anno ed era finito ci avevo finito
tutte le zone ok però il gioco è
effettivamente lo finisce quando compie
quando prendi 60 st wright ed adesso per
andare a vedere esattamente signora mi
credi adesso che giocare la scadenza di
marzo e lily fammi vedere un attimo
quanto quanto è tornato sul gameplay 15
oddo non so registrando in questo
momento e lo sto registrando molto prima
questo che il 20 febbraio il 20 febbraio
del 2020 l'ho iniziato il 15 febbraio
del 2003 ci sono esattamente sette anni
cinque giorni sette anni precisi da
quando ho iniziato scrivendo ai miei
tempi che capo led
poi l'ho fatto il mago in realtà io vi
ripeto lo avevo finito solo che la
storia vera e propria si finisce col 60
strike che non hanno mai raggiunto hanno
molto contento e anche molto commosso
devo essere sincero perché tutto ciò mi
ha riportato un po ai vecchi tempi po
come se queste fossero i titoli di coda
allen you will you back però cerco di
non piangere andiamo avanti parete li
deflusso facciamo un altro paio di st
wright tanto che ci siamo
benvenuta rete di deflusso della
capitale sette anni da belice nel 2013
tra sette anni fa vj farà le cose
incredibili sette anni dopo due funghi
siamo ancora qua gli altri pesci
continua a prendermi in giro d'italia
mandarli via
ok squalo magnate tutti e pesce tifone è
l'unico che si è salvato fantastico
comportati d'amico aiutami a scappare ma
che poi machisti ma chi ti conosce la
scappa ma come la collega cosa vedo non
è possibile
vabbè io volevo fare esattamente
l'opposto brom è scappato cosa
importante adattarsi
ho vissuto qui e non conosco il mio ho
sempre vissuto qui non conosco mi
aspetto specchio meglio non conoscerlo
fai cagare per ottieni si è rotto e
quello che c'è dentro che conta ragazzi
io vi ho io allora sono passati 7 anni
appurati in sette anni io veramente in
modo veramente poche volte ho trovato un
gioco che fosse in grado di superare
scrive l'ansa a livello di genialità
perché si vela e geni e ragazzi scrivere
e geniale e geniali intanto puoi fare
quello che vuoi è bellissimo i marziani
stanno invadendo la colonia lunare crea
qualcosa che mette in fuga i gatti
alieni invasori cosa cani alieni alieno
cane alieno cane alieno kaki alieni non
dei cachi alieni porto dell'oman un cane
fa niente anche i cachi i gatti sono
scappati ma ora i marziani hanno fatto
sbarcare zombie spaziali sembra la
fatica ma qualcosa per nutrirli cervello
te
stavo magnate fate un po a turno perché
ce n'è uno solo ecco sarei mangiato solo
l'alieno fantastico sì però ragazzi
spostatevi voi che devo fà il matera
distrutto l'intera fattoria crea un
posto in cui vivere che resisterà agli
attacchi dei marziani
e che ne so un posto che resista i
fulmini
solo ieri che cosa fuori lista di
fornitori ciapa la macchina non è una
cosa resiste cosa resiste i fulmini un
posto di gomma casa di gomma gommosa go
go go cosa casa unifamiliare di gommate
di gomma la gomma non è conduttore non
va bene forse perché un po troppo
ballerina ma che non vi fate l'abitudine
ragazzi se vivete due giorni poi posto
ora gara porca put un rifugio hamburger
bunker tenco htc dentro madonna un
casino ci ho messo due ore per capire
che devo fare un bunker da vede niente
c'è una pianta che si sta ingrossando
aiuto la faccio fuori io poi quel che è
necessario per portarci diffusi da
questa creatura faccio io fratello mio
papà orco demonio è diventato un
insalata e così che cucino li salate a
casa anche effettivamente se uno
specchio
occhio che ti riflette il fulmine no
cara beh non c'era arrivato proprio che
non doveva essere comunque non ce l'ho
mai riva e la madonna l'hai fatta coi
lego st straw nave ma che è ma cos'era
va bè ragazzi st wright mega meritata 61
tra tono presi mammamia videogiocatore è
vero ho finito scrive la è veramente
passato un sacco di tempo ma mi ha un po
commosso sinceramente questa roba mentre
guardavo il filmatino però ho finito
comunque scrive l'oms prima di prendere
la patente quindi fantastico speriamo vi
sia piaciuto che passerete subito
piaciuto al 100 come è un mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale e noi signore come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]